[Applaudissements]
j'ai grandi dans un tout petit village à
peu près 500 habitants il y avait des
choses que j'entendais depuis petit
comme ils sont pas comme nous ils nous
prennent notre travail ou a préféré on
est chez nous ici
alors bon naturellement au bout d'un
moment j'ai décidé de partir de voyage
est d'apprendre d'autres cultures de
découvrir d'autres langues d'autres
façons de manger de tomber amoureuse
d'étudier et je suis rentré ya cinq ans
en france forte de toutes ces
expériences que j'avais pu vivre à
l'étranger
hélas deux copains nathanaël et
guillaume m'ont dit viens on va lancer
un mouvement citoyen international qui
va permettre à des personnes réfugiées
quand elle arrive dans une nouvelle
société de créer des entreprises de
rencontrer des français d'innover et de
faire partager en fait toute leur
expérience
alors évidemment ça m'a emballé je les
ai rejoints
on a lancé singa qui est devenu
effectivement un mouvement international
dans lequel il ya des centaines via des
centaines de milliers de personnes en
tout cas et là j'ai rencontré ina en
septembre 2015 on a fait un seul fils et
celui là c'est le sel fille de deux
copines qui se rencontrent qui se
racontent leur vie qui partagent leurs
passions leurs espoirs leurs échecs
mais comme je les dis c'est une photo
qu'on a prises en 2015
c'est le moment où tout le monde parlait
de la crise des réfugiés réfugiés
c'était le mot que tout le monde avait à
la bouche
c'était assez envahissant en fait mais
pour nous ça voulait pas dire grand
chose mais pour beaucoup de personnes en
fait cette photo c'était la photo d'une
française et d'une réfugiée
mon premier année en france j'ai passé
en refusant de prolos langue française
c'était lié avec le peur d'être extradé
pendant le procédure de demande d'asile
je reste et donc d'aller chez moi
pendant un an plus en plus des primaires
j'ai essayé plusieurs cours de la longue
mais c'était pas marché j'avais plus
d'énergie j'étais pas motivé ma famille
me manque je t'ai revente d'affection et
j'avais une forte sentiment d'être une 0
dans cette société française car j'avais
l'habitude d'être impliqué dans mon pays
dans les actions solidaires du politique
c'était ma manière à me sentir à ma
place dans la société où j'habite la
france c'est un pays qui m'a pris dans
ses bras c'est un pays qui me donnait le
protection il société qui m'accueille et
moi j'ai donc envie de le remercier de
donner une sens de ma présence de rendre
tout ce que me donnait la première étape
de cet engagement et commencer par le
sport qui a une passion pour moi depuis
j'étais petit j'étais accro
ce petit nage artistique athlétisme
natation box plusieurs types du sport
j'ai donc décidé de lancer le projet sur
l'intégration des personnes réfugiées
par sport dans la société française avec
des groupes mix entre site en français
et père sont réfugiés tout est gratuit
dans une cadre de détente et de partage
première étape c'était d'envoyer des
lettres aux l'association qui travaille
sur l'accueil des personnes réfugiées
j'ai envoyé deux différents l'être au
plus aux différentes associations
et seulement une qui m'a répondu et
c'était singa quand je travaillais avec
tsonga j'étais très étonné parce que ma
pas traité comme une réfugiée qui est
venu demander quelque chose on me
traitait comme un homme se prénomme 12e
étape pour moi c'était cassé des
stéréotypes des barrières psychologiques
et des linguistique entre personnes
réfugiées et des soutiens français ayant
des idées dans la tête sur les
changements de la société sur sa
libération de préjugés et de
discriminations
je trouvais mon moyenne personnel de cet
attrait boudé ce mécanisme de libération
c'était le création grier grâce à cette
création de liant et la communauté singa
j'ai rencontré tellement personne dans
ma vie
des féministes des persos avec des
idéologies politiques similaires aux
différentes que moi des sportifs de
rencontres combat avec alice s'était pas
que rencontrent cet officier amitié
cette personne qui veut dire qu'ils
variante vers nouvel horizon tessi en
france tous ces gens ils sont devenus
mes amis mes proches
ils sont tous remplacés ma famille ici
dans ma nouvelle vie à que j'ai eu en
france
alors avec l'ina quand on a commencé à
bosser ensemble moi j'entendais
vachement parler de ses opinions
politiques
mais ce que je connais c'est d'elle
c'était l'aspect entrepreneurs quelqu'un
qui voulait changer le monde
créer des liens entre sportifs de toutes
les sociétés et un jour on est arrivé à
parler de la place des femmes
moi j'étais assez engagé dans plusieurs
associations notamment stop harcèlement
de rue et on s'est aperçu d'une chose de
moscou à paris les femmes subissent des
violences
que ce soit du harcèlement ou d'autres
types de violence alors je lui ai
proposé de rejoindre l'association pour
qu'on aille dans la rue faire de la
prévention auprès des victimes de
harcèlement ce beau jour j'aurai souvent
à une message d'alice pour la
proposition de vignobles d'un avis d'une
association féminine généralement des
rencontres avec des français avec moi
c'était fini toujours pas me poser des
mêmes questions pourquoi je suis réfugié
pourquoi je suis là
comment je suis venu en france en bateau
où il n'a pas beaucoup de travail dans
mon pays donc du coup j'ai été beaucoup
des vignoles en plus si je connaissais
pas très bien à lille on a travaillé que
single et je connaissais pas du tout et
ses amis normalement quand je rencontre
des français je croyais pas que je suis
réfugié je dis juste que je suis venu en
france seulement pour mes études
beaucoup je prends tout mon courage
sharif et là surprise il a personne qui
m'a présenté comme un réfugié
je suis une femme copines comme tous les
autres mais les tentes on ne partagent
leur expérience moi je partage mon
expérience sur la situation des femmes
en russie on est tous ensemble contre
cette caserne de la société de sexisme
l'homophobie se journée j'aurais trouvé
des copines et des copains j'ai trouvé
une nouvelle force
je me sens pas seul il existe des
centaines dina et des centaines d' alice
des personnes qui ont juste envie de se
rencontrer de partager des passions
si naïvement on est devenus amis c'est
parce qu'on s'est ouverte l'une à
l'autre et parce qu'on a partagé nos
points communs nos engagements nos
combats et des personnes comme ina qui
sont réfugiés qui arrivent en france il
y en a beaucoup qui a envie de
rencontrer des français
cette année on a eu la chance de
rencontrer aissam aissam c'est un jeune
de 21 ans qui cumule pas mal de
stéréotypes arabes musulmans réfugiés
syriens émigrer mais en fait à l'esam
c'est aussi un poète un musicien un
rappeur un passionné alors quand il est
arrivé à singhai nous a dit qu'il aimait
faire de la musique bon très bien on
avait un atelier musique et qui est
animé par deux jeunes de son âge qui
s'appelle romain et thibault et quelques
semaines plus tard ils m'ont contacté
tous les trois et m'ont dit ali c'est
génial on va monter un groupe de rap
on va tout plaqué dans notre vie et on
va créer une association pour faire en
sorte que les gens se rencontrent autour
de la musique que le rythme en fait
casse les barrières linguistiques les
barrières psychologiques et barrières de
timidité et qu'on crée du lien
finalement à travers la musique et ça a
cartonné
ce coup là aujourd'hui c'est un gros
merci pour eux aujourd'hui c'est un
groupe de musique franco anglo arabe
enfin c'est les trois langues en tout
cas et tous les jours il crée du lien
entre les gens en fait singh a fait des
bébés d'une certaine façon est
finalement eu ça a été leur manière de
prendre le large
ça allait ça a été d'aller au bout de
leur passion et de faire ce qu'ils
aiment et faire ensemble sans tenir
compte finalement des stéréotypes qui
pouvait y avoir derrière toute cette
barrière arabe aux réfugiés etc
et moi je décidé de prendre la large
avec le sport c'était pas seulement que
pour ma passion mais aussi c'est un
formidable moyenne d'intégration dans la
société façon en justice inégalités de
la société ne sont remplis sans mais
dans le sport on ne juge pas sur le
statut social sur le compte bancaire
j'ai décidé de faire un tour sont les
centres d'accueil des personnes
réfugiées à paris moi je poserai si moi
j'avais des difficultés à rencontrer des
français d'autres réfugiés sont archi et
je me suis pas trompé des femmes des
hommes des comme rooney des afghanes
pakistanais sais rien sont tous avaient
des difficultés de rencontrer des
français il suffit juste organiser un
match de foot
une séance de fitness au yoga pour créer
ces rencontres aujourd'hui je suis
plus inaf les réfugiés et je suis pas
seulement une féministe une sportif mai
2016 on a gagné le prix d'honneur de la
mairie de paris sur les femmes en sport
j'étais tellement étonné parce que c'est
moi je suis réfugié cessez vos projets
pourquoi on me choisit je suis en bas de
l'échelle et là on m'appelle pour
recevoir ce prix aujourd'hui je suis une
étudiante je suis plus allé réfugiés je
suis chez une personne qui veut
construire une onde meilleur sans le
peur sans le discrimination et de
préjugés
des histoires comme celles d'in à moi ça
me fait toujours un peu frissonner et
j'en rencontre pas mal des personnes qui
arrivent dans un nouveau pays et qui
tout simplement veulent faire profiter
tout ce qu'elles sont à leur société
d'accueil
quand j'allume les réseaux sociaux que
j'écoute l'actualité je sais pas pour
vous surtout cette semaine mais je
panique un peu parfois je panique parce
que j'ai l'impression que en france
passer un petit peu comme dans mon
village
quand j'étais petit et je commence à
être de plus en plus persuadé qu'il y
aura un vrai changement
à partir du moment où on arrêtera de se
poser la question de ce que les autres
les étrangers peuvent nous prendre et
qu'on commencera à se demander ce qu'ils
peuvent nous apporter prendre le large
c'est aussi chez soi que ça se fait en
osant en dépassant ses craintes en aller
en en allant à la rencontre de l'autre
et surtout de soi même et même parfois
en faisant un peu de sport ou en allant
coller des affiches dans la rue
[Applaudissements]